thank you for joining us kabul's
international airport is up and running
a civilian commercial flight has taken
off from the afghan capital for the
first time since it fell to taliban
forces last month
these are exclusive pictures of the
plane leaving it's a domestic service
bound for the northern city of maasai
sharif its departure follows repairs to
the runway and radar with the help of
technical teams from qatar
and turkey
let's bring in charles stratford who's
live for us in kabul charlie an
important day today for kabul airport
even if it's not fully operational yet
that's right a very significant day
in terms of afghanistan's hopes for
being able to have access to vast
amounts of desperately needed
humanitarian aid and being able to
freely move around this country and
potentially around the world as well um
we understand that there has been a
second commercial flight taken off since
that that one to maza sarif earlier
another commercial flight having taken
off for herrat
we have seen an incredible effort put in
by technical staff especially from qatar
and we believe turkey also in recent
days
trying to put in as much
repairing of um various of the runway of
various bits of technology reinstalling
things like radar and so on
bear in mind that according to the un
around half this country's population
that's around 20 million people are in
desperate need of urgent humanitarian
aid
so the opening of this airport although
it is just the beginnings is of huge
importance
and earlier today we had the qatar
ambassador who was down on the tarmac
and he was speaking to the media let's
have a listen to what he had to say
via
and we are doing an assessment of the
progress so far also assessing the
damage that was done by the masses of
people who had come to the airport
hopefully in a short period of time we
will be able to achieve everything we
have been able technically to put the
airport in operation and you can see
this aircraft just landed and more will
come tomorrow and the day after tomorrow
depth more diplomatic moves have also
happened today in kabul the head of
pakistan's spy agency the isi faiz hamid
has come into kabul we believe for talks
certainly
we understand possibly with the with the
countries and now pakistan have huge
importance obviously uh
a large neighbor sharing a border of
around 2500 kilometers we understand the
focus of the attention will be on
pakistan's security and refugee concerns
pakistan already plays host to around
three million afghan refugees from
previous conflicts and war
and although the west has accused
pakistan or accused elements within the
pakistani military
and intelligence in the past of actually
helping to fund the taliban which of
course the pakistanis have hugely denied
there is no denying that pakistan does
have influence here over the taliban and
is very keen obviously to see stability
here because of the potential
ramifications across the border pakistan
is also potentially being seen as a
linchpin between the west and the
taliban so yeah diplomatic movements on
that front as well um but uh some
positive news today out of kabul from
the airport thank you for that charlie
charles stratford live for us there in
kabul well let's now speak to aviation
specialist alex macheres who joins us
via skype here in doha alex very good to
have you on the show so as charlie said
there an important day talk us through
the kind of work that went into getting
kabul airport up and running again the
airport i understand was in a terrible
state a lot of damage to the runway
basic infrastructure destroyed
what are some of the equipment and
technical systems that were needed to
get to get it up and running again
well it's still very early days folly
and that's because afghanistan as a
country right now is still without air
traffic control provisions the flights
mentioned by your reporter on the ground
are currently being told that they can
only be domestic flights and so they are
afghan airlines and also they are only
able to operate in the daylight hours
and that is because right now this is
still an airport that is pretty much
totally off limits not just to the rest
of the world but it's still not yet fit
for any kind of significant
return of commercial service that
afghanistan had just a month ago but in
terms of the technical teams that are on
the ground now we know that qatar
in collaboration with turkey are leading
the efforts to ensure the basics the
fact that the runway and the surface of
the runway is secure and intact because
there was a lot of damage that was
reported after the dramatic events on
the 15th and 16th of august in addition
to that we know that they are working to
try to secure an element of air traffic
control provisions
that are primarily for aircraft that
require little to no assistance in
arriving really to deliver aid they are
very reliant on that aid as you
explained and and so having these
military aircraft to be able to come in
is that priority first i was going to
ask you about the priorities now as you
say the airport is not fully operational
what is the top priority right now
because everyone of course wants to get
aid into afghanistan what needs to
happen at the airport for that to be
possible
well there needs to be some kind of
establishment of a security that's first
and we know that qatar say that they are
in talks with the taliban to try to
convince them that they must accept a
foreign security presence if this
airport is going to welcome back any
kind of commercial airline jet be it
passenger or cargo um
muhammad abdul rahman the foreign
minister of qatar told media yesterday
that he was convincing the taliban
aviation security is a little more than
just securing the perimeter of the
airport site itself we need to have
the international community assured that
there are people qualified individuals
on the ground
able to supply air traffic control
provisions able to guarantee the safety
of these aircraft and i think we are
still a way off of that at the moment
right now we will have only these
aircraft that are able to
ultimately use the environment in an
uncontrolled manner but it's not
sustainable for the long term and that's
why these efforts are underway to
ultimately establish something that is
more sustainable and has the technical
support and how long alex do you think
until we see international flights
operate again from that airport
there might be a political element
involved in that i imagine
for sure so what we know at the moment
is that if countries like qatar and
turkey with their nato allies are able
to secure the airport site in a manner
that gives the assurance to the rest of
the world in terms of security and
safety for airliners then that message
will be spread among the aviation
community but to be very honest folly
it's going to take a lot of convincing
and reassurance to have a foreign
airline fly not just over afghanistan
because overflight is off limits now too
but to afghanistan we're talking about
aircraft that are insured by third-party
companies and leasing companies that
will say no airline you are not able to
take this aircraft there because we
can't guarantee that it will get out in
the state that we require it and so on
there are so many complications and
hurdles to overcome the provisions of
fuel for example will these aircraft be
able to be refueled on the ground or not
engineers on the ground you know the
worry about the brain drain and the fact
that a lot of skilled personnel have
left afghanistan what does that mean for
situations unfolding with aircraft that
are going tech for example so all of
these hurdles have to be cleared and
it's going to take a lot not just to get
aircraft to fly over afghanistan a very
key overflight region but to have them
operate to and from the country thank
you so much for talking to us alex thank
you for your insights always good to
have you on the show alex machias
joining us there from doha